Kevin Bacon you did try to do the thing
I was hoping to Diane about about trying
to go out incognito to not be Kevin
Bacon I had a disguise built by a
special effects makeup artist yeah was
it like a fake nose Ionis a classic okay
are you are you that I'm wearing now
Kevin Bacon yeah I'm like about that so
bright well did you like people not
recognizing you well I tell you you know
people don't talk about the fact that
being recognizable is 99.9% good because
people are nice to you all day long for
absolutely no reason people stopped in
the street said Kevin I love you I mean
who doesn't want to be loved right who
doesn't want to have somebody say I love
you Jessica Tom I love it I mean that's
it that's a great that's a great feeling
and you can get out of tickets and you
know they'll give you free sneakers and
like that so anyway it's mostly
good it's my point once a while you try
to think to yourself like what would it
be like to just walk through the world
anonymously so I decided to you know
experiment with that and it worked I
mean you can't it mean obviously I had
to done by professionals and applied by
professionals and and you definitely
didn't know it was me and I went to
there's a outdoor shopping mall in
California called the Grove which is
sort of like the worst place to eat it's
the worst place you want to walk around
if you're a celebrity yeah you're that
you know that's that's a guaranteed you
know yeah place that you could be taking
some selfies and I walk straight through
the Grove and nobody recognized me and
it was awful
going back to town baby
[Applause]
[Music]